これじゃあどっ2うーん
始めた松本潤出る本来の寝れねードアあの
鋼材の魔女まずネルは新キャラが居ますねこちらのこの人
魔女さんということでしんちゃんのバージョンサンとこのバカみたいですね今回ソニー
式でね仲良く仲良く寝ねるねるねをつくっていくわけなんですけども
ここ5年でって名前なのかなことは名前だったこのバカみたいな奴だねえと言うな
前ガラスですね
何が普通でるでるでるんと違うかというとこちらに3つのキーワードがあるわけですよ
発パッチするもっと膨らむで味が変わるこれはでもう活気としかいう話題に出る出る
出るんですよ
今までのねるねの全て味な変化がなくね美味しいんですけども
特殊な効果はなかったここですのエフェクト3つ加えた上での挑戦ということで
同じ三角カップに水を入れて市コナミの粉を入れて
8パツポーンよくわらないがトレーンで国がね今回目をつけたのポイントはもっと
膨らむという点このまずロズウェルなぜクラブことができるのかといえばす操縦そうと
言うねふくらし粉が入ってるんですよ徐々にはアワーのもたが入ってれ本の山と反応し
アンさんが出てスクール
ブラッシングでございますそこで洞窟で遊びが考えたわけさ
そう私今から10袋ぐらいまず場所寝るを準備したのでこの
まずまず寝る便はいや逃がし
ん
ご視聴ありがとうございました1年はこのまずまず寝るを10分は全部ここに打ち込ん
で最初にこちらの炭酸水素ナトリウム重奏を準備しましたこれは月の重曹です
まつげない大丈夫だまあまだも何かやりすぎたら死にそうだなーかっこいいなー薬てぃ
強いからなぁやりすぎるとしてるんは知らないけどやっとぴょこ
第二保育所もう重曹入ってるんだがさらにそれね重曹変わることによって大爆発がおけ
るんじゃないかと思うわけよてるで今回はベレーでネットワークさせてみようと思い
ますこれの scientific
普通に食べてるよあの真似すんなよの中層はね直径をだから危なくはないけど多量摂取
は危険な薬品なんで相次ぎてさっそく1つの作っていきましょう
まず実際に作ってどんな感じの子ちょっと試してみたいと思っている枚がたシンプルな
うわっっこの奥にポッ
ってなるわけね作らが5つありますどう2はじめとした個余分な作業省いて省いて吹い
て効率的な授業していきたいわけなのだよまずはなんだ一番この虚礼の丸い形に入れ
ますそこに三角カップ1杯の水を入れスってよくますよ
はいされでもできたんだろうとかあーの事例だってこの3コップに水を入れてきてそれ
をここに入れますすぐ
入れてスプーンでよくかきますよはい adam 次に版のほなを入れ移動が変わる
言えばてよく混ぜ良いも味が出るで音をかけていますねまだながら色が変わってきた愛
これがとりあえずリング味の面でねー
さっそく食べてみようまあまあこれ使ったらこの3つの話味が変わる魔女のこず袋すっ
するコブクロ膨らむ方ねちょっとフレーズ実験的に入れてみますこれで果たして膨らむ
かどうか
たぶん今重曹と車道さんが反応してるねーまさには膨らんでいる途中だと思われますが
そんな変化なくねこれだけで本当に水入れなかったさあどうでしょ
多少はね量が多くなったような気がしますよまあ
こんなもんかなあの合図で俺はこんなも the bells アンサーにこれを入れ
たパチパチするらしい
うまい
媒体まいっかよはんだけど海風がめんどくさいんだよねまず一番の粉
そいやそいやそいやそいやそいやそいやそいやそいやそいや市の花投入完了です
水で人に入れてきました早く混ぜなきゃ頑張って水
お前の力はそんなものはないはずよもっともっとちゃんバレルでさぁ
できるできる君ならできる
ほらみんなも元気に元気にできるできるてー3
ちょっと待ってこれはヤバイ者馬鹿な人次は2番の子な色が変わるまで入れて混ぜます
ん
ふう知らせして行ってきたが色が変わるまで混ぜれば多分いい感じだとあでも割とある
んだーはっきり分かんだね
なかなか減税で盛り上がってるの存在だいぶ量が変わってきましたコーラずだったら
思ったんですけどもっと膨らむこっちの粉を先に入れるとさんが反応しちゃってコッチ
のガーゼの重曹と反応する分の3がなくなるどころか見たのでこの
もっと膨らまずのコーナーを使いません直接重曹でいきます感動できるよう決まってる
ねこれは何だ何か良い様になってきたじゃねーか
パチパチの子供に出てきますいやんもういた
パレットほとんど人妻ともうそんな人ってほとんでくるのどんなに強いかえぜベイたら
ヤバいんじゃないですかこれ
love ないよウードゥー year
ちょっとなくなっちゃっていやーずは待って本当に怖いあのガッツで飛んでくるんです
よしこんなもんかな
じゃあ全部混ぜ終わったのでこれでございは完成ですここから自薦ジュースを打ち込ん
でこれがどこまで膨らんでパク髪っていうかみー所でねっあっはぁああぬううそうあの
させると湖しました
これを一気に入れてかき混ぜてどれだけ膨らむかです注ぎ月いきましょう
先ずっと化しておこもうねやばいこれついて好きだから
パー擁立早速重曹投入します捉える
水21 fire
方に中層方はこれがどう反応するかですからちゃんと
深読みところだと思います来たぞどうなるどうなる
ん
he
まあ
こんな場所
味でアジアジアジ
あれ糞不味ああ
うわぁやばいうずら良い